when you're sitting in a math class and
the teacher starts writing some symbols
on the board that you might not quite
understand just yet it might be tempting
to say hey why do i need to learn this
this seems a little bit abstract for me
and to answer that i'll tell you a story
that one of my early advisors told me
when i was just starting khan academy
and this is someone who doesn't come
from engineering doesn't come from
science
doesn't come from mathematics
he's actually a major restaurateur who
has a chain of restaurants some of you
might have gone to and he says
when he hires people he thinks about
whether they understand algebra or not
in fact in his mind he divides the world
into people who understand algebra and
people who do not understand algebra and
the reason why he told me he does that
is he says
when people understand algebra it gives
him confidence that they have the
critical thinking and analytical skills
to tackle pretty much any problem in any
domain and i think that is the practical
reason why algebra is so powerful it's
really going to start to fine-tune your
critical thinking skills and your logic
and beyond that it's frankly just
beautiful
a lot of the equations you're going to
learn and the ways of manipulating
equations philosophers mathematicians
were developing these for thousands of
years and now you get to understand the
outcome of their thousands of years of
hitting a head against the wall and
coming up with these beautiful
expressions that are are really the
fundamental truths of the universe so
when you go into this algebra journey
that we're about to start learn the math
learn the tools you're about to because
it's really a form of expression it's a
form it's a way of representing pure
ideas in the universe and our minds in
these lessons we're going to talk about
some of that history and the origins of
algebra we're also going to think about
what is an algebraic expression and what
are things like unknowns and variables
and finally we're going to really start
to build out our toolkit on how do we
manipulate these things how do we speak
the language of algebra and utilize
these tools to solve
everyday problems so let's start this
adventure together there might be
moments where you're a little bit unsure
of yourself where you're a little bit
not sure of how one thing leads to
another but trust me
if you go into the content pause videos
and see if you can solve things on your
own before i work through it with you
and then make sure again that you can do
it on your own and i encourage you to go
to khan academy.org and practice these
same concepts on the site where you'll
get immediate feedback to make sure that
you're understanding them
algebra is going to be a powerful
toolkit not just for your studies but
for your entire life